[Music]
the premise of the movie is set far in
the future because of excessive and
unethical use of natural resources the
world faces a new pandemic every year
that kills billions of people humans
have started to see life as a curse as
they can catch a deadly virus and die
any time then one day amidst all the
disaster a scientist named pilate comes
as a blessing to humankind he makes a
genetic discovery that can turn humans
immortal giving people hope to live in a
fairy tale void of the fear of death in
a short time he invents the practical
use of the discovery and the remainder
of the human race transforms into
eternal beings the scene changes to 200
years in the future the system of
immortality has changed now only a
select group of people who live inside a
domed city get a chance to go through a
process called the freeze which makes
them immortal pilot runs the entire city
and has hundreds of employees working
for him to maintain order people at a
young age are brought to the domed area
and are evaluated by pilot himself he
pinpoints the moment in their life when
they are at their peak which is when
they get the freeze for most people this
age is around 25 but it can vary from
person to person hence the domed city is
filled with immortals and people looking
to become immortals in the future then
we are introduced to the protagonist of
the film logos he is being moved into
the city alongside multiple people
excited about their transformation
unlike them logos has many questions in
his heart he doubts that immortality is
a gift humans need because to him death
is what binds life together without
death there is no living there is just
existing despite such concerns on his
mind logos enters the city hoping to
find answers on his second day in the
city he is approached by a woman named
suker she has sensed that he has been
questioning immortality and is here to
invite him to a group one that is made
of more people like him she hands him a
box that is supposed to take him to said
group without being tracked pilate and
his right hand man armoros are watching
the surveillance footage when they see
the box and find it suspicious pilot
asks armoros to find out what the box is
somewhere else a tour guide ak is
telling a bunch of new students about
the process of freezing one of the new
citizens inquires about someone who used
to work closely with pilot ak reveals
that there was once a man who was as
smart and intelligent as pilot they were
partners until the man protested against
the system of immortality and his memory
was wiped clean as a result no one knows
where he is now but rumor has it that he
has invented a program to end the entire
immortality system before disappearing
ak is later approached by armoros who
takes her to meet pilate virtually the
man wants ak to spy on logos and find
out what he is up to since she is a
guide looking to be promoted into a
guardian it is a perfect way to test her
abilities in the following scene ak
catches logos and sucre together and
eavesdrops on their conversation but a
smart sucker already knows that they are
being watched she talks to logos in
circles and tells him to come to the
church later but to ak it sounds like a
normal friendly conversation later
pilate is told this but he refuses to
let go of the matter he again asks ak to
continue to spy on logos and make a
report about all his activities to do so
ak has to be close to him hence she
approaches him the next time she finds
him alone she comments on the book he is
reading and starts a conversation about
immortality right away logos asks her if
she believes the things she tells her
students as their guide it makes ak
think and she registers that she doesn't
have an answer the following day she
appoints a set of twin sisters to spy on
logos while she is not around the twins
are also hoping to be promoted so they
accept the job in an instant at the same
time logos goes to the church and meets
sucr after confirming that no one has
followed him he is allowed inside a man
named masim welcomes him in and
introduces him to a programmer and
scientist medoran everyone in the group
is like logos they question the
immortality system and are unsatisfied
with pilot's method it is then revealed
that people are given a dosage of a drug
named maintenance every day to
supposedly prepare themselves for the
freezing process but the group has found
out that the drug makes them submissive
suppressing human emotions and instincts
they cannot love or hate which makes
them incapable of protesting against
what they dislike it is almost as if
they are bred to become pilots slaves
everyone who takes the maintenance drug
is the same but for some reason logo
seems to be immune to it which is why he
has thoughts outside of the benefits of
immortality the scientist midorin has
found a diary made by pilot's former
partner and is replicating the virus
that will overturn immortality the
group's primary goal is to make people
realize that they can feel happiness and
sorrow so they protest against the
system and end pilate's rule in the
following scene pilate is with his
teenage daughter amanda she inquires
about his ex-partner and reveals that
his name was helios amanda is a curious
girl she has many questions about the
system her father runs which normal
citizens would not be allowed to ask in
a way she is like logos and the others
from the group and pilate has started to
realize this as well in the morning
logos wakes up because of a nightmare he
has been having a recurring dream where
he is in the desert wearing a hazmat
suit the dream always ends with him
struggling to breathe and passing out
aka is adamant about the promotion and
is willing to do anything to complete
the task pilot has given her that day
she approaches logos again posing as
someone who wants to be his friend
however in the middle of the
conversation she asks him if he takes
the maintenance drugs that prepare him
for the freezing process logos is taken
aback by the question but he lies and
says yes after some time he is with the
group that is planning to disturb the
flow of maintenance drugs by changing
the code which can be done from the
capitol building this is sure to show
people how it is to feel human emotions
but to recode they need access to the
underground tunnels of the capitol
building logos remembers that ak works
in the capital and her card can be used
to gain access to areas that are
otherwise not open to the general public
he goes to meet her and asks her if she
takes her maintenance drug before she
answers the twins interrupt them we see
amaros asking ak what logos was talking
about but she lies to him and claims
that he just came to say hi logos
question remains on her mind for the
rest of the day hence she eventually
goes to meet him he trusts her and
brings her to the rest of the group
revealing every step of their plan and
their goal to someone who has been sent
to spy on them ak is shocked but she
composes herself even after finding out
how pilot is controlling them she
doesn't comprehend the severity of the
situation thanks to the maintenance drug
she has been consuming every day ak is
even more stunned when the group asks
her to help them with their plan she is
given some time to think it over but she
takes this opportunity to tell amaros
everything she discovered surprisingly
enough he remains calm for someone who
has been told about a rebel group who
wants to end his boss's rule armoros
asks ak to return to the group and agree
to help even though she fears being
caught she trusts armoros to get her out
of any unmanageable situation in the
meantime we see pilate talking to amanda
again she inquires about what it was
like when he lost her mother pilate is
fed up with her asking him the same
questions but he replies that it was
devastating he also reveals that one
time amanda was close to death and he
thought his life was ending with hers
this is the reason he and helius worked
hard to create the genetic coding method
however pilate claims helius was jealous
that he got all the credit which caused
a rift in their friendship after hearing
everything he has to say amanda comments
that the last part changes every time he
tells her the story then we see ak come
to the rebel group offering help they
create an elaborate plan and assign
specific tasks to everyone before
finally executing it but when they sneak
into the building and are about to enter
the tunnel an alarm rings this is
actually ak and armoros's plan to
separate logos from the rest of the
group and arrest him it works and
eventually he is captured and taken into
the medical room the doctors perform a
memory wipe on him causing him to forget
everything ak feels terrible for doing
what she did to logos after finding out
that his memory was wiped she protests
that she wants to meet him but pilate
warns her to do only the things she is
asked to moreover her presence might
trigger some memories in him ak is
distressed for a few hours before the
twins inform her that they saw logos
earlier ak runs to meet him but he fails
to recognize her he has also been given
a heavier dosage of the maintenance
medicine which has turned him into an
immortal he doesn't feel any pain or
happiness in ak's head he is a living
dead not an immortal it is then revealed
that ak has also not been taking her
maintenance drug since the day she was
told about pilot's true intentions she
finally realizes that she has made a
huge mistake and runs to meet the rest
of the group ak cries apologizes and
begs for forgiveness but the group
doesn't trust her anymore she then tells
them about logos and how he has been
changed into a robot without memories
after repeatedly promising that she has
realized the truth the group counts her
in as their teammate again in the next
scene they abduct logos from a mental
facility he was being kept in they begin
recovering him while pilate finds out
about the disappearance he also
discovers that ak was involved and
blames armoros for not being careful
enough with the people he employs
somewhere else after talking to ak for a
few hours logos finally starts getting
glimpses of the past although he still
has a lot to remember he figures out the
group's purpose and is happy to rejoin
them in the following scene the group is
planning to continue their plan to hack
and reprogram the maintenance system
since ak is not a member of the capitol
anymore she asks for help from the twins
it works and they gain access to the
underground facility they are eventually
successful in changing and overriding
the program while they are at it the
group is fortunate enough to find
diffusers that can be used to turn
people from immortal to mortal then we
see the entire group escaping to the
city they take shelter in between the
mountains by building tents suddenly
logos has an epiphany and uses the
diffuser on himself desperate to feel
emotions he passes out right after which
scares everyone the doctor of the group
helps him and he returns to
consciousness in a few hours aka who is
scared for him finally admits that she
has started to like him logos also tells
her that he feels the same in the
following scene the group finds out that
pilot is launching a new program today
that will strengthen his hold on humans
he wants to deliver a live message to
his people but the system is hacked by
the group instead of pilot logos appears
on the screen and tells the people
everything about pilot's unethical way
of controlling everyone he asks them to
think freely at least once and promises
that everything will be crystal clear to
them after that the people are riled up
upon hearing the long speech armoros
tells pilot that they must stop the
group as soon as possible but pilot is
cool as a cucumber assuming that his
system can never malfunction and the
general public can do nothing after that
ak comes into their view with the
diffuser she uses it and turns herself
into a mortal at last comes amanda with
a twist she reveals that before dying
helius stored his cerebral data his
emotions his thoughts ideologies and so
on into a hard drive which has been
downloaded into her brain in other words
she is helios in the last scene ak
narrates that amanda is the key to
returning humans to their natural form
she is hopeful the group will soon be
contacted by her subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching